man my opinion on Cat Williams bro I
know Cat Williams he's a he's a crazy
individual very talented up until his
third special everybody said Cat
Williams the best comic in the world
when he started going far left or far
right and not aligning up with everybody
else he gave the chance for Kevin Hart
to come in nobody was talking about
Kevin Hart so when he started [__] up
it gave people to be like oh who's this
new little [__] and I think Cat Williams
at his ripe age of
53 four whatever it is it's bitter
because like where my where my TV
shows yeah where my movies like you [__]
up bro I mean bro I've experienced cat
William personally oh really